hey guys my name is Jess and it is
Friday which means I'm here to get you
all caught up on what's been happening
in gaming this week first up there's
been a little bit of drama / / watches
less-than-optimal refresh rate a refresh
rate or tick rate determines how often
an online game updates for hosting
server every second overwatch features a
20.8 refresh rate we're ideally you'd
want to be at around 60 for a shooter a
low refresh rate can result in you
taking damage while in cover or having
that crucial ability activates just a
little too late in custom made games
overwatch gives you the ability to raise
the tick rate to 62.5 but you can still
experience lag if other players live in
different regions well is that have said
they are listening to the response to
players using the higher refresh rate
and in the process of collecting data
that have not said whether they're
planning to introduce the feature to the
game's main modes Final Fantasy 15
director Hajime Tabata has opened up
about what he calls a final fantasy
disease while commenting on the
development struggles of Final Fantasy
15 Tabata explained that there was a
sort of final fantasy disease within the
team and among fans he said that it
refers to people who can't imagine
anything other than their own via Final
Fantasy adding if that view of final
fantasy isn't fulfilled then they
convinced that it's bad final fantasy he
said they needed to overcome this and
resolve to modernize final fantasy to
make it as good as it can be alright so
now I have something a little bit
special for you it's a feel-good story
so if you've been having a crappy week
this one should go down a treat
nine-year-old Bryce of Cleveland Ohio
has three years worth of pokemon cards
in a binder stolen from him by quote
some kid when he was walking to a
friend's house although the binder was
eventually found some of the cards had
been stolen since we've all been screwed
over by some kid in our youth the police
officer who took the report of the crime
named James groped in Wrath decided to
kindly donate his own collection of
pokemon cards to price the officer said
he
was just happy to make the kids smile
again and I'm not crying you're crying
let's do the next door a number of
reports have suggested that two new xbox
one models are on their way between now
and the end of 2017 it's expected that
an Xbox one mini will hit shelves this
year which will be forty percent smaller
than the xbox one and feature a two
terabyte hard drive then next year it's
been suggested that will be getting a
new model of the Xbox one codenamed
Scorpio which will have a more powerful
GPU be technically capable of supporting
the oculus rift and run at six teraflops
which is four times the power of the
Xbox one and almost two teraflops more
than the upcoming ps4 neo if reports
proved to be correct finally this week
it looks like no man's sky has been
delayed kotaku have reported that
multiple sources who work at gamestop
said they received marketing materials
for no man's sky with the original jun
21 release date however stores were then
informed that the release date is no
longer correct and they should cover it
up with a coming soon label neither Sony
nor hello games have commented on the
rumors although since then TechRadar has
said to independent sources also
verified the delay the extent of this
delay however has not been disclosed let
me know in the comments what you cared
about this week and how you feel about
the rumored no man's sky delay this week
on site Lucy asked how Napoleon would
have said with orcs I take a look at six
of the coolest units you can control in
total war war hammer and we roll through
the best Easter eggs you can find in
tune that is it for me this week as
always thanks for sticking around to be
sure to have yourselves a great weekend
and I will see you again on Monday